the director
as we graph in life we are taught that
he who dies with the most toys wins I've
gone through my life thinking that Moyes
better and that I'm defined by what I
have keeping up with the Joneses you
know but does this make us happy
I wonder if there's another way a hump
of happiness every Wednesday
good friends of mine have decided to
leave the rat race behind and unplug in
an off-the-grid home I have come to
spend the weekend with them and wonder
what I may learn from this experience
you know normally I'm so distracted by
everything around me what's on my phone
who's doing what
it's almost strange to be mindful of the
simple pleasures like collecting my own
food
honestly like most of you I'm not ready
to leave the city and just completely
osika what I have realized is that
everybody can make a difference
it doesn't mean unplugging completely
the brother realizing that it's failing
more time in nature growing your own
food not wasting or reusing water buying
this stuff and sharing what I have feels
right I'm gonna start small the changes
that I make don't have to be late but
I'm gonna start today I hope you guys
enjoyed my last hunt of happiness
remember to be mindful of the small
things please let me know what you
thought in the comments below and
subscribe because next week I have
something very special planned also make
sure you subscribe to Green Renaissance
their forms are incredible I'll link
them in the description below